[Musique]
ça me déjà pas à me dire on décrète de
la vie si tout en louant une astucieuse
plus sérieux n'avait pas joué il suffit
de vouloir revenir à sa vie
oui je regrette toujours la question
qu'est ce qu'il ya mais qu'est ce qu'il
ya je suis trompé mais enfin je suis
tombé ça peut arriver mais tu t'es fait
mal on ne faut pas jeter la pierre à une
invasion qui tombe enfin mon pauvre tout
qu'on voit là où cela s'est passé si on
leur fait dire à un terrain ça va mieux
là voilà sa main gauche en belgique
comme en c1
absolument bonjour à tous et à toutes
dit bonjour excuses - bonjour excusez
moi je pense qu'il a eues mais vraiment
il a dû sert mal le pauvre alors la
géographie oui de quel pays parlons nous
les mains de celui qui est sous la fleur
envoyer c'est exactement le découvriez
rieux coprah alors on commence par la
carte de géographie du pays sa tension
me retournant à sarko malsam alors un le
drapeau du pays et anzin bon je me dis
qu'on bonjour dans la langue du pays
voilà bon voici tout d'abord suivez-moi
bien la carte de ce pays
pas facile je dois dire pas facile pas
facile il faut même presque très
rapidement le drapeau je serai une
ouverture sur la mer la capitale est ici
c'est un pays je ne sais pas je vais
regarder le drapeau à voilà un drapeau
qui est assez simple dans sa forme
oui je vous précise les couleurs blanc
en eau et rouge en bas blancs en eau et
rouge en bas en vie s'il s'est un petit
peu difficile oui mais on devrait tout
de même pouvoir y arriver
voici bonjour dans la langue du pays
16e d'aubry diane d'oubli diane de bris
oui viennent de bris écoute moi je crois
qu'il devrait s'agir de la pologne
c'est ça c'est la pologne voile s'agit
la pologne avec sa capitale qui est
varsovie sans drapeaux et en polonais
dieng aubry ont tout va qu'on s'en sorte
qu'encore finalement dans le foot pro
n'arrive à tous
il faut réfléchir un petit peu il va
même peut-être pouvoir arriver jusqu'aux
jardins à bon tu veux je m'en aille des
gens voient j'ai compris j'ai pas
comment on dit au revoir aux polonais
non moi non plus bon alors voilà les
primaires a dit donc poursuivi j ai
amené les petites soeurs aujourd'hui à
bien faire elles sont très gentils sont
manière là bas sont violés mathieu
ravignat though he zhi bon on appelle
fabris ont mis à bas prix fabrice
fabrice abri ont banni les petites
soeurs aux eyzies fond la zone asie est
pas bonjour aux eyzies elles vont jouer
avec nous oui oui oui parce qu'on a
besoin d'elle
le jeu du point commun le jeu du point
commun alors le jeu du point commun je
vous le rappelle tout cas encore joe esi
et pousse moussu sont des choses ou des
objets et c'est tout le problème
consiste à savoir quel est le point
commun qui les unit voilà bon alors
écoute bien un ouvre grand tes oreilles
aujourd'hui je vais te surprendre bon
parce que je suis quelque chose que j'ai
beaucoup utilisé quand j'étais petit mes
parents avaient décidé de me faire faire
de la dose tu vois tient dans bah oui
ben y'a pas dire stade où j'ai étudié la
danse à et là ça ne se voit pas tous les
jours là il m'en reste quelque chose tu
vas voir bien regarde cette souplesse
l'unfd team omlt des entrechats et les
virevoltes hd tu vois les pointes sur
les pointes n'a pas de stand up d'un
gang
tu vois le rythme dans la peau avec
leurs rites et ne répare tout cas encore
t'énerve pas tenable au rebond alors tu
vois ça représente des heures et des
heures de travail
oui et puis voilà 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
voilà c'est tout oui pourquoi mam ça un
site à nous oui c'est à vous les filles
c'est paris c'est paris c'est différent
de tout propre à cet effet
on est là nous sommes à ses parades
évidemment mais la lame alpes et la même
couleur
et puis on est toujours l'une à côté
[Musique]
même si igor tout comme nos despotes ont
seulement ma vie on ne se dispute pas ah
oui eh ben je sais pas j'ai pas arrêté
de rigoler je fais pas vraiment écouté
parce que c'était tellement drôle mais
je vois pas bien ce que ça peut être et
sympathique
[Musique]
oui d'accord pouces mutuelle santé elles
sont incroyables bolat a alors eh ben
moi je représente quelque chose qui est
indispensable pour le calcul mais
addition soustraction multiplication
pour tout ça on a besoin de moi tu sais
fabrice je suis pas très fort en
orthographe un oui c'est ça alors mais
alors mais alors pour le calcul je ne
crains personne 2 et 2 4 4 4 8 8 et but
c'est sa ds3 2 c'était un accès de rage
toi je pourrais continuer comme ça très
longtemps alors les multiplications
c'est la même chose tu me demanderais de
multiplier 34 par 17 et bien j'écrirai
34 et puis 17
et puis je tirerai un trait forcément un
et c'est ce trait que je représente
aujourd'hui voilà tu vas je vois je vois
à 6 ça y'est au dernier moment je viens
trouver mais vraiment alors au dernier
moment parce que avant je dois vous
avouer je nage
complète mais ça y est je crois que tout
quand qu'on nous a parlé de la danse
vous savez que lorsqu'on est dans ce
danseur on s'entraîne énormément très
dur et on fait une barre nos deux
petites jumelles lattes et peut-être des
barres parallèles par exemple pour faire
de la gymnastique 1 et je pense que tu
étais une une barque long mais lorsque
l'on fait effectivement une addition ou
une multiplication ménard sous les
chiffres voilà msa est pas vrai eh ben
je suis très content de moi c'est une
bonne chose
je me contente vous également eh bien
merci ea sports ea bow valley voir si on
retrouve notre petit ami devait oui
d'accord sans revoir les soeurs -
beau-frère et basse orwell louise y
aller pour les uns je crois que c'est à
nous et à nous alors tu vas au tableau
comme je vais y aller oui je vois très
envie de me lever pour sont les vacances
là bas chercher au tableau alors puis
mais le sur tes genoux manquait
cependant ce ne serait pas bien pour nos
petits amis à givet quand même alors
suivant c'est bien pour te faire plaisir
parce que je sens que tu encore me faire
écrire des soties non cette semaine
c'est très facile mais c'est quoi c'est
un petit mot très courts fête commence
par an s'il être d'abord oui
ainsi l'être et ça commence par un à un
alors 1 2 3 4 pour les lettres qu'ils
mangent oui et on finit par un n 1 n
voilà voilà voilà alors alors jetez moi
une fleur
non c'est une plante c'est pas une
plante alors un animal c'est un animal
bord c'est un gros animaux au nom d'un
petit un tout petit animal qui volent de
à des files mais il doit vivre iphone
ils sont réels est ce que c'est un
animal que l'on trouve en france
est ce que c'est un animal qui est joli
oh oui le palais
les geôles il est assez jolie julianne
belle teinte amis est ce que cette
analyse est ce que c'est un insecte oui
oui qui avance bien
j'avance j'avance je cours je te donne
une lettre oui j'aimerais bien oui alors
la deuxième lettre c'est pain n 1 n
monde parle don baylor je pense que si
certaines n
alors on pourrait peut-être aussi à un
oui alors il coûtera plus de stu et
gentils tous les serres ce que nous
avons à fait insisterait battoir touques
encore s'il te trouve alors continuons
on peut continuer est ce que c'est un
animal avec un m1 âme mais non non non
non non ça ne fait pas un insecte dans
banane bien sûr que non 1 1
arnaud à ton jeu que tu as trouvé ta
trouver un hanneton mais je il va me
faire mourir je me dois me faire mourir
nous habitons un tout gros dan regarde
comment ça s'écrit anne tanguy h1 ou
encore alain weill à 1h
on est fâché avec les acheteurs ensuite
il y a 2 n
en plus il ya 2 et wii à ton mais tu
fais rire tous nos amis qui te regardent
ils savent tous et kieran ton avis
dartout viendra la surchauffe oise ou
pas moi tu sais je sais pas ce que je
veux bien toi naturellement ça tu es
complètement égal comme toujours
oui moi j'ai quand même quelque chose à
vous d'apprendre leur vie se passe
presque entièrement sous terre et il y
reste pendant des années sous la forme
d'un gros ver blanc
et puis un jour ils deviennent les vrais
halte on voit là une sorte et ils vivent
un mois ou deux sites noirs maximum
eh ben c'est très bien voilà retrouvons
bell bell voilà la petite
[Musique]
tu n'as pas de risques à jouer avec moi
côtoient des notes de musique la sorte
et musical oui qui dit encore exactement
ce qu'on va faire
oui bon ben tant pis toi parce que la
seule âgées aux aides et en asie
et bien qu'elle aille m'est arrivé
d'avoir extraordinaire et je ne suis pas
encore remis à la bombe figure toi que
lorsque je suis revenu chez moi ce matin
à présidera les fermes au marché au
moment de mettre la clé dans la serrure
j'ai senti qu'il y avait quelque chose
d'anormal
quelque chose de mystérieux me l'a 28
mystérieux j'ouvre la porte doucement je
découvre à mon pauvre ami un spectacle
épouvantable mon appartement ressemblait
à un champ de bataille une véritable d
une quoi une des nations ne dénote une
une joie pas d or le dessin la seule
apparemment surpris s'il était sens
dessus dessous et que ça parce que l
affaire est traitée mal faire mais on ne
vient pas de déroger tout le temps nous
avons un jeu il est très compliqué de
riz ce que tu veux dire c'est au lycée
presse de livrer la forêt bien voilà
alors j'ai fini mon histoire totale aux
électrices animaux de tous mes voisins a
vite envahi mon style en quoi mon cas
qui s'il il faut trouver est la place de
poumon il faut mais bnat ses bases et
ben tant qu'on rayman est on me fasses
ton sol console pour la cet incident
ton domicile
tongs aux missiles bien sûr domi on se
dit si c'est aujourd'hui un jour lucie
eelv y avait deux choix de lacoste ch à
gros prix yamoy premiers mois un gros
chat siamois si si olalala il m'avait
avec ses griffes arachides tous les w
brienon vide le sage de la voisine du
dessus qui étaient venus se joindre à la
fête
il faisait des points malgré devant le
poumon droit
dès ses magrets voilà devant le wa au
vent le pou moi devant le dôme alors et
moir le même - le fameux moi le seul
voir leur relation la zone noire que le
poisson rouge qui avait sauté de son
beau gars il se trémousser sur le tapis
de la bouche ouverte
comme si on allait rouler dans la peau
brune est passé à la poêle à la poêle
oui mais avant il avait roulé dans la
farine
non là s'arrêter alors même que j'ai me
faire me suis mise à pleurer
oui à pleurer à fleurier pas s'affoler
les choses pour moi m nita vais te donne
est en toi ça va s'arranger très bien il
ya une note que j'ai sauté quand même ce
plat qu'elle s'était montrée pièce est
une des belles c'est parce que je n'ai
pas trop vu dû sauter la barrière et de
vignobles rue schuman pour chanter et
ben j'arrive tout de suite tant pis pour
moi j'avais qu'à trouver à l'est
l'étape ni japon voit pas les amis les
quatre ont tenu secret que la vie majed
s'est désisté et rzeszow des chances les
tops juni pas de mémoire
il faudra faire attention les quatre
amis sont pas cotées sont réunis et ça
me fait de retards isère la vie
voici ses amis
seniors conflit
les caries ça oui vous avez bien joué
aujourd'hui
ici le vouloir devenir azami imsi de
vouloir devenir un ami
c'est vrai ça
[Musique]